[Music]
all right everybody
officially welcome into the draft crash
course adam lefko connor rogers today's
episode is sleepers and hidden gems as
always
welcoming everybody on br youtube
gridiron twitter
and of course in the br app that's the
only place where reading comments
submit your videos in the nfl draft
community if you send one in
and we play it you get a hoodie today's
episode is sleepers and hidden gems
but before we get into that i want to
talk about some news and rumors connor
justin fields he had his pro day there's
a picture of kyle shanahan and they're
smiling and everyone's happy
not luca doncic asks justin fields is
good
is he not pretty simple question but i
just want to talk about the fields pro
day overall connor
yeah i mean number one he's very good
he's the fourth best player in this
draft if you ask me i think that's
pretty good and he's one of the better
quarterback prospects
of the last five years left go now when
you look at the pro day
this was a really good opportunity in
this year to have a second pro day
because
teams were able to send a different trio
of people let's not forget you can only
send three team representatives so
in most cases when you're investing that
selection in a quarterback a high
profile quarterback
a quarterback that's going in the top 10
picks no matter what mock drafts you
read out there
you want everybody in the building to be
unified on this decision so the first
pro day
you're probably going to send your gm
your head coach and then you got to
choose but you're probably going to send
your offensive coordinator
a trend we've noticed with a lot of
teams picking in the top 10 or the top
15 at the second pro day is
you could send your quarterback coach
you could send your director of player
personnel
you can send a wide receivers coach you
could have said what's the buzz on
fields right now
connor that he's still a really good
quarterback
that he's in play at number three for
the 49ers no matter how much mac jones
hype you hear and i've been saying this
every week
i've never been one to be sold that mac
jones was a lock at number three
it's interesting to see a lot of people
start to walk back from that right now
this is a long month left go you've been
through this many many times
how many people are walking back the mac
jones
at three lock right now how many people
i think a lot of people
in the national media are starting to
not act like it's the lock we once
thought it was
and i think this is an interesting
three-man race between mack jones
between trey lance who is somebody i
believe was going to be the pick when
they made this trade
and of course justin fields and when it
comes down to it you have to ask the
question
is mac jones a guy that you're going to
trade three first round picks for he's a
good quarterback prospect make no
mistake about that
but is he somebody that you mortgage
your entire future on
when a situation where you're sitting
there and you're saying hey we're
betting on this guy to be a future
top 10 passer in the league i don't
think a lot of people including myself
are
believing that with mac jones but it's
easier to see that future carved out for
fields or trey lance with the special
talent that they have
so number three of this draft is going
to be fascinating we're going to be
sitting on that desk
waiting for it to unfold and it just
goes to show you this is no
lock for any of those three guys yet i
just want
an updated weekly thing this does not
mean this is what your final pick is
we're going to be live on draft night
bleacher report all that stuff uh right
now
how do you where do you see these
quarterbacks going not
zach wilson not trevor lawrence as we
record this on thursday
i'm gonna go with my original prediction
as it stands i think trey lance goes to
three with the 49ers now
i do think this is the toughest one to
predict because justin fields is a great
fit in that offense
and you've heard all of the hype around
mac jones and then ultimately
i think the number fourth pick in the
draft is going to be for sale by atlanta
this has been a long process for them
to figure this out did we take our
quarterback in the future sit him behind
matt ryan for two years
and then let him go the way they
restructured matt ryan's money tells me
that
they're not gonna do that right now and
then logistically it just makes the most
sense to trade out of that pick and get
the value and get a lot more assets for
the future with a new gm
and a new head coach so i think we're
gonna have a team move up to four
whether that's the patriots whether
that's the broncos whether maybe the
bears or washington tries to get in the
mix
i think number four would be a really
really no-brainer decision to take
justin fields as well
so when it comes down to it i think
there's gonna be five quarterbacks taken
in the top ten of this draft and just
because the panthers got sam darnold i
don't think it's 100
luck that they don't take one if the guy
falls as well
let's get to our big topic for today
which was sleepers
and hidden gems really quickly
how do you designate whether someone is
a sleeper or hidden gem what is the
connor
rules they have to be a day three player
in the eyes of the nfl consensus for me
right now i might bump these guys up
into round three sometimes when things
get crazy around too
but the general rule of thumb is that
they are expected to go on day three
adam lefko
and a lot of the guys that we talk about
today might not even be drafted
i love wide receiver sleepers so for our
first one
give me a sleeper wide receiver i likely
have never heard of
yeah antonio nunn from buffalo let's
start right there coming from an
offense that does not throw the ball a
lot this is a player that was
phenomenal in the mac but if you have
questions about his level of competition
watch the plays right here against penn
state i mean this guy
is a really really good player good
acceleration off the line of scrimmage
he knows how to vary the speed in his
routes
and what i like about him most lefko is
the late hands
is the ability to trick defensive backs
and get his hands up
right at the arrival of the football and
he's got a little juice after the catch
the 10-yard split it matches that
acceleration a 1 5 6 10 yard split is a
very important number to me for a wide
receiver and just goes to show you
this guy knows how to get open in that
10 to 20 yard kind of range that matters
so much
in the modern nfl so i look at antonio
nunn and say
hey i value him pretty early on day
three
do i think he's going to be drafted at
some point absolutely i look at a team
like the seahawks
they don't have a lot of picks they
could use another player on the back end
of their wide receiver
room that can come in and make plays
right away a reliable underneath target
i really really like antonio none in
seattle and i like the player overall
there's been no buzz about him
it's probably because of the lack of
overall eye-popping production
but don't blame him blame the offense
watch the plays and opportunities he
does make
because he takes advantage of all of
them i have a very simple brain
who does he remind you of who's his pro
player comparison
that's a really good question and
honestly i don't really see one for him
yet right now i think when you look at
it
the player comparisons are going to go
in the top 100 kind of guys now
if you're looking for i'll give you a
poor man's version because people
overreact to player comps but the poor
man's version of me would be chris
godwin somebody that knows how to
function
in and out of the slot catches
everything his way
those late hands that body type that
more compact muscled up body type so
there's a you know an exaggerated
version yes
but if you are looking for the play
style that's the guy
i have heard there's a lot of really
good slot receivers in this draft
finally it's a position that's getting
it's just due we have an app comment
from duron msn
don't sleep on smith marsette he broke
records guess what consider me snoozing
i don't know enough about this guy
connor does he fit into your sleepers
he absolutely does i'm glad that we got
this question because he's on the
sleepers rundown when you look at amir
smith marsette the speed is what jumps
off the tape to me for him
he's returned two kicks for touchdowns
in 2019
he knows how to win vertically he's not
the strongest guy at the catch point
but he knows how to take the top off of
the defense and i think iowa just wasn't
creative enough with his skill set i
think that
in this modern nfl that uses a lot of
motion that uses a lot of jet sweeps
teams that like to use screens and allow
their guys to get up field
i think that's what you're looking at
for him and you want to talk about a pro
player comparison he reminds me of paul
richardson
someone that is a slender kind of body
has really good speed off the line of
scrimmage
knows how to win down the field and i
just think there's more production for
him at the next level than what we got
to see for the hawkeyes
i am a huge fan of underutilized
position
players that never get their just due i
like that so what were you thinking
possibly for him if you were to go on
day three
i look at the colts right you got your
boy carson wentz there
they're a team that they tried to get
these vertical threats in the past they
did a nice job trying
to get you know ty hilton back on a a
team friendly deal but he's been banged
up over the years
homeless six games yeah they
you know they took paris campbell early
a couple years ago somebody else that's
missed time with injury they're still
trying to find a down the field
target a consistent one but they know
how to do it at wide receiver at
bargain value so i think when you look
at amir smith marsett
he's more of that fourth round fifth
round kind of player for me
and that fits the strategy of the colts
under chris ballard and that dodds
mbr12 says i have smith marcetta's my
outside wide receiver five emanuel
sanders 2.0 tm
42 i agree he's another massive sleeper
i like those
uh what about a running back do you have
a running back sleeper for me
yeah i'm going to go with elijah
mitchell i think when you look at him
coming out of you
yeah with eliza elijah mitchell coming
out of louisiana just
really good straight line speed left go
now he has a lot of experience as a zone
runner in this offense
but i think when you can get him
downhill you can see that 4-3
kind of speed a good body to run like
that
i do think the contact balance was
pretty good you could see him stay on
his feet
and he knows how to make a move at the
second level of the field so
this is not my favorite running back
class this is not the typical running
back class where you sit there and go
hey we can wait until day three and get
our starter but if you look at someone
that's coming out of a committee
that has experience not only as a zone
runner but also gap opportunities as
well man blocking schemes
he's a polished player in that regard he
can come into a committee
and take some carries and that's why the
fit for him would be the denver broncos
we know that they have their workhorse
runner already there and melvin gordon
you know how things end with phillip
lindsey
you know they have royce freeman as the
backup but you still need
one more body in there behind melvin
gordon who's also been banged up
throughout his nfl career it's gonna
happen playing running back in the nfl
so elijah mitchell a really good
downhill runner
enough speed to be an outside runner i
think he fits the broncos committee
and then just kind of looking over some
of the notes that i've seen he's an
after
contact monster huh yeah he really is i
mean this is someone that
broke over 40 tackles i believe and had
500 of his rushing yards after that
initial contact so
in this offense there's a lot of plays
where he's the first defender is getting
to him behind the line of scrimmage and
he knows how to keep charging forward he
knows how to stay on his feet with that
contact balance
and when you have that kind of speed
you're a bit of a weapon in the second
level of the field so
once again it's not the most exciting
running back class on day three but i
look for players with
traits and experience and with
mitchell's speed
and a lot of production and you heard
mike renner say it on last week's show
from pro football focus
one thing that tends to translate with
running backs in terms of numbers
is miss tackles force and that's really
the name of his game
offensive lineman that you can find on
day three can change your franchise
now sometimes these guys go earlier than
we think just because the value of
offensive lineman but who's someone
right now that you have targeted
as a third day guy that could be a
sleeper
it's kendrick green from illinois who
has experience
at guard and center the athleticism is
off the charts and i think when you look
at kendrick green all of these teams
running wide zone rushing attacks are
going to fall in love with him because
of how quick he is getting to the second
level of the field
climbing to linebackers it really jumps
out with him and
in a league that's always looking for
versatility along the interior offensive
line
green's got that like i said starts at
left guard starts at center
485 440 for a guy over 300 pounds
36 inch vertical jump left go i have
thoughts that this offensive lineman can
dunk
he really really plays with an edge as
well considering he's not the biggest
offensive lineman
on the field so the fit for me would be
the new york jets they went out and gave
conor mcgovern a pretty good contract
two years ago to be their center
he has experience at guard i think if
you look at kendrick green at the top of
round three pick
66 or maybe even pick 86 that seattle
third rounder
you sit there and go we'll kick connor
mcgovern to guard well
kendrick green at center a way better
scheme fit for what we want to do
bringing over these guys from the 49ers
to coach our rushing attack and now
you've upgraded two spots you upgraded
your center position
you've upgraded from alex lewis or greg
van rotten that guard
by kicking mcgovern over so kendrick
green's getting slept on
he is the guy on this list that is not a
day three player although he gets viewed
as one
there's no way he belongs in that day
three conversation
when i think about centers that can run
i think about jason kelsey and let's not
forget
jason kelsey was a sixth round pick
athletic centers that can get out
is a mismatch that certain teams just
don't have right connor
yeah corey linsley another guy that was
a late pitch i mean it happens it
happens every year left going you look
at the athletic comps for green if you
go on a site
like mock draftable or one of these
sites like relative athletic score that
has
comparable numbers to show these guys
green is in a league of his own left
goal when we do the draft show
i color code my doc for things that
stand out if you
get that c blue that icy blue on a
number
that means you're in the 90-plus percent
island green had that in the 40-yard
dash
he had that in the vertical jump as well
you just really don't see
athletes at the interior offensive line
like this guy
and the film is good where it's not a
question about technique or anything
like that so
he's someone that excites me in a league
that is really starting to move towards
more wide rushing attacks
let's also remind everybody that when
you go to game day as an nfl roster you
might only bring in
seven or eight offensive linemen and to
have a guy that in case a guard goes
down a center goes down can do multiple
positions
you are instantly more valuable let's
take a break right now from sleepers and
hidden gems
people that have listened to the left go
show know if you want to make money
you take connor rogers advice on prop
bets i believe he said
months ago to take matt jones under 15
that bet right now you're not going to
find that anywhere because it just
sounds ridiculous
so connor i got one for you naji harris
the line is at 29 and a half
so you're really betting does he sneak
in at the
end of the first round would you go over
under
and by the way just to clarify under
means he gets drafted beforehand
right yes it does and to answer this
question let go
i think he goes under i've made a lot of
calls on this exact topic the last two
weeks
hey what's the deal with the running
backs because the more research i did on
the back end
the day three guys like elijah mitchell
i sat there and went
man if you need a starting running back
and you miss on naji
you miss on etienne you miss on javante
you miss on kenny gainwell
good luck you're throwing darts at that
point it is not a running back class
that's very deep so i look at naji
harris
and i think the conversation starts with
the pittsburgh steelers there
i believe i picked 24. so when you look
at it
i don't see him making it out of the
first round i don't see him going after
pick
you know it would have to be pick 30 and
above naji harris is going in the first
round in my eyes a
rare three down runner he could pass
protect
he can catch the ball he creates with
the ball in his hand he creates his
own yards at the second level of the
field everybody's freaking out about no
40 time
i've watched the tape for quite a few
years i mean even going back to high
school but at his college level in the
sec
he runs away from sec defenders no worry
there
i take the under all day on this one
miami would be interesting at 18.
pittsburgh now would be interesting at
24 with james connor signing with
arizona a few interesting teams sounds
like there's not a lot of cam
acres in this draft okay devonta smith
will undoubtedly be the guy that will
define
draft evaluations look what he did in
college
but look at his frame i've heard the
marvin harrison comps i see the over
under
at 11 and a half is he going before that
or after that oh
under or over a little more risk here
but i'm going
under and the reason i think that is if
you're the new york giants picking
at 11 you you went out and gave kenny
gallaudet a lot of money sure
but you've really stuck your foot in the
ground and said daniel jones is our guy
and he has to be for someone like dave
gettleman to keep his job
you're going to keep stacking the deck
left though you're going to give him all
the weapons in the world
and if you passed on devante smith at 11
uh i know a team in the division that
you're familiar with that would like to
draft his services at the wide receiver
position
in the philadelphia eagle so for devante
smith
there are a lot of alabama connections
on that new york giants staff they've
done their homework
if he makes it to 11 i just don't see
how he gets by them
if they don't take him at 11 and the
eagles reunite jalen hurts with devonta
smith
i will be very excited on draft night
that's something i can sign up for
because you know where marvin harrison
was born and lived philadelphia
sounds like it's finally coming full
circle i would like that a lot okay next
one
penny sewell many people see him as the
best
left tackle prospect in this draft i
know there's a lot of talk about rashawn
slater maybe being
more physically imposing the over under
i have here is six and a half
so what vegas is saying is will he get
past the dolphins at six
what's your read under over yeah and
they started to backpedal on this one
when i got it and it launched it was
five and a half and that goes to show
you how many people took the over that
they already bumped this up
and i'm still gonna take the over on
this i think when you look at it let go
we had this conversation with andrew
whitworth on the first ever draft crash
course
there are a lot of teams in the nfl that
have rashawn slater as the top offensive
lineman in this strategy
when i look at when i look at penne
sewell he's someone that's going to be
20 years old the first month of his
rookie nfl season and he's already this
talented at left tackle so i don't
understand it he's the number two player
overall for me
in this class but the more conversations
i have
i do think he makes it out by p he makes
it out of
pick six i think he's gonna be more
towards it might even create a
conversation for the cowboys at ten do
we have to take this guy as our
offensive line ages why
why because you know what it is i think
that teams
like they view slater as this finished
product they view him as somebody that
has reps against chase young
and looked the part but outside of that
it's hard for me to get on board i've
heard people say that
you know sewell doesn't have the same
balance in pass pro
i don't get it the size is there the
author that's what i'm saying take out
take out the comms to rashawn slater
penny soul as a prospect what are they
dinging him
for i just think they feel he's a little
raw
in pass pro right now that he's somebody
that can get in a habit of lunging and
once again i don't see these i don't see
these things enough evident sample size
on film where it's an issue
everybody said this for mikai bechten as
well that he's not technically the
perfect player
but when you're you have these kind of
feet at that size you're a dancing bear
you're that nimble
nobody's getting by you and when you can
move bodies to the sideline in the run
game
off the screen it doesn't matter so yeah
yeah yeah he's not just playing against
the pac-12 and even if he was we get
pass rushers out of there so
with penne sewell it's a classic case i
think of the league overthinking this
one he should be the first offensive
lineman off the board
but if i'm a betting man i feel okay
about the money of him getting out of
pick six and going somewhere between
seven to ten
yeah i think i'm seeing a lot of people
right now wanting to reunite
jamar chase with joe burrow which seems
to be precipitating this fall so we'll
see okay let's get back to sleepers i
want to reunite jamar chase with joe
burrow is what's going on there
and you know what what joe barrow wants
joe borrow gets let's take our sleepers
over to the defensive side of the ball
uh pass rusher is that's what's been so
interesting about this top ten
because usually it is quarterbacks
offensive linemen wide receivers and
pass rushers and there's just none that
are up there
so i want one a a third round fourth
round
sleeper that maybe we're missing on here
who do you got for me
yeah it's gonna start with cam sample
from tulane in edge pass rusher more
hand in the dirt kind of player
that i really like i think he's a top
100 player
i think he's somebody that could sneak
into day two i think he's got
powerful hands he controls the point of
attack he knows how to bull rush
he puts on a show at the goal line he's
somebody that
does not want you crossing the goal line
into the end zone and
he understands leverage he understands
how to get on the inside of offensive
lineman's pads
that are much bigger than him who he
reminds me of lefko by saying all this
trey flowers another edge rusher that
went very very late
late in the draft considering the talent
and how reliable he was
against the run a power rusher it's
funny he's got a player across from him
patrick johnson that's a totally
different style edge that i like
cam sample is the the power guy he's the
i can run
through you kind of player and so sturdy
against the run so
i look at i know they just signed an
edge named davion clowney
but i look at the cleveland browns now
you don't have to take that edge guy at
26.
you don't have to do it at the end of
the second round you can you have two
third rounders you can wait a little bit
to take cam sample you don't have to
take one in the first round
and you can rotate him on the field we
know clowney's injury history
there's a reason that deal is loaded
with incentives of him being
on the field being on the 46-man roster
so they still need a little insurance
there but man
cam sample is somebody that i think he's
better than a lot of the edge rushers
that get more hype
uh i have been a fan of doing these
dream draft recently so you're saying
the browns let's say they get him
in the third round build me the dream
draft for the browns
one two and they have two third round
picks
so they still have a needed off ball
linebacker so round one at pick 26 let's
get zabin collins from tulsa somebody
that is a really good athlete
can run and cover ken blitz good range
against the run
and he's kind of a freak show i mean i
compared him to anthony barr
the same exact athletic profile not a
lot of players that are
260 plus pounds move like this
and you see the linear speed the ability
to come downhill
and crush the quarterback he does the
same thing against the run
so for the browns they got help on the
edge
they've built a really good roster over
the years where they don't have crazy
needs
you have a little bit of a needed off
ball linebacker take saban collins
around one player
round two let's get a deep threat in
diamy brown i know they have two
starting receivers i know they have
higgins as a third guy
but you gotta be thinking two years
ahead in the draft sometimes left go
this guy wins vertically over and over
again if you want to try to jam him at
the line of scrimmage
you better show up with those hands you
better throw those hands or that's going
to happen to you so
listen the browns wide receiver room
might look a little different after this
year
get a head start on it now in a great
wide receiver class and somebody that
tracks the ball really well
wins vertically threatens vertically i
think he has a little more juice after
the catch than people are giving him
credit for so the browns
you get a athletic off-ball linebacker
round one you get a deep threat wide
receiver in round two
we talked about cam sample already in
round three but you got
another third round pick let's get that
rotational nose tackle and tyler
sheldon somebody that did not play this
year i mean this dude is an
f-350 left go 350 pounds he just
eats space in the middle of the field
can two gap
he's not going to play every snap he's
not going to be asked
to rush the passer on passing downs but
to each space in the middle of the field
against the run
tyler sheldon is a good value pick there
at the end of round three
i'll tell you what that north carolina
wide receiver there's certain times
where you can just put on tape and you
go he's got those road runner legs where
the other guy's legs are not moving that
fast
uh my favorite comment after you went
through that dream draft was tm 42
who said jesus that draft is insane
i just want to get a little bit
different into the amc game
i will say i forgot it's going to be big
for the browns to get grant delpit back
that defense kind of struggled a little
bit late in the year
they could really make some big strides
now that you got jadivian clowny and
miles garrett on opposite sides
it's going to be a lot of fireworks
there uh do you have another edge rusher
for me that could also be seen as a
sleeper
tell me about this patrick johnson guy
you talked about cam sample
i could see there was a twinkle in your
eye when it came to patrick johnson
man it's funny let go i got to the
tulane tape in april which is very late
in my process
and i said they have not won but two
edge pass rushers that are top 100
players that are day two picks
patrick johnson is the anti-cam sample
the only thing that's the same
is they understand how to use their
hands but he is
all speed and first step off the edge
he's explosive
off the edge a really good first step
and he's got an array of pass rush moves
whether it's that outside speed rush
where he turns the corner
i've seen him work an inside spin i've
seen him counter
inside he reminds me of d4 not somebody
that you want
hand in the dirt first down or second in
short stop the run
hold the point of attack no this guy
knows where the money is that's the
sacks getting after the quarterback
creating plays creating turnovers i look
at patrick johnson
he excites me when you could stand up
and rush with that kind of speed off the
edge and turn the corner
it doesn't matter the level of
competition because that's going to work
at the next level
that is a translatable trait we see work
over and over again
so patrick johnson to me i know the
vikings have some
have a need at edge they could use a
little bit more pass rush juice on the
outside
assuming even if denial hunter comes
back healthy
i like the scheme fit there in minnesota
patrick johnson knows where the money
resides
good to know uh by the way that
linebacker that you showed earlier is
even collins
that was an athlete any time i could see
a linebacker in 23
that was some special stuff i want a
linebacker that will not be going in the
first round i want a sleeper who do you
have for me
yeah tony fields from west virginia a
transfer of west virginia with tony
fields
it's really the opposite it's all
instincts right it's that's not what
steven collins is david collins is all
athlete
with tony fields it's i'm gonna read my
keys you see him moving before the snap
he knows where the ball is going and you
see it in coverage as well he just knows
how to read
everything underneath the read and react
the hustle when they did let him blitz
a big time hustle player he's not the
biggest guy in the field he's not the
fastest guy in the field but he just
understands the flow in front of him and
how to shoot gaps
how to make plays i don't even think
lefko he'll be a third fourth maybe not
even a fifth round pick
and it would not shock me if he's a sub
package linebacker early on so tony
fields
all he's done in college is make plays
and smart linebackers stick around in
the league for a long time
even if it's just on special teams so
you know i look at the packers they have
a need at linebacker maybe they don't
want to invest in early asset in one
they want to get more of a bargain
player
they want a guy that's smart and has
four years of starting experience
on his plate had a really good showing
at the senior bowl i think green bay on
day three is where i would look at tony
fields
let's go to that back line secondary
safety corner
whichever you want your pick connor
who's the one that jumps out it's a
hidden gem
well let's get a mix of both divine
diablo how about that name diablo
he's a big safety he's somebody that is
just
he's built like cam chancellor and he's
got these long
arms he could sit in a cover or two
shell you can have him sit single high
he could play the slot
he comes downhill like a thumper you see
the big body and guys just bounce off of
him
divine diablo is somebody that in round
three would really excite me what i like
to call
match-up player lefko he can run the
scene with tight ends he can run the
wheel with running backs he could sit
over the top in coverage
and get physical you'd like to see him
come down with that one but his teammate
should stay out of his way
so he's just one of those players that
is
all traits based you love the length you
love the size
you love what he can do in coverage and
in the league that someone like johnny
smith is out here getting the k
the get in the bag kyle pitts is going
in the top 10.
you need these big body safeties that
can give
at least a chance against these tight
ends
and you went to virginia tech and for
all the
people in their mid-30s out there it
just brings me back to the time of
uh macho harris and those incredible
runs of safeties there at virginia tech
who could you see and by the way divine
diablo
like wonderful devil oh my goodness
where is where is divine diablo going to
end up
i look at the dallas cowboys i think
they can use one of these match-up
players
in this division and the cowboys i mean
they have a chance to do something
special
in this draft it just seems like they're
in a sweet spot across the board
when you look at all the picks and
they're a team that they've
kind of given a half-hearted effort at
safety over the years right they're like
we think we can get by with this guy
we think we could sign this guy for one
year or we can draft this guy
in the sixth round maybe it's time to
make a little bit of an
investment not a crazy one a third round
investment where
you have two third round picks i think
he'd be the first of those third round
picks
but i think for the dallas cowboys for
dan quinn
we know how much he loved to use keanu
neil as this kind of hybrid safety
divine diablo would be the similar
similar way i see the fit
before we get into the dream draft and i
know we're coming up against it
why is he not seen as a higher draft
pick just from what i'm watching right
here he looks great
i think he is and i think he's one of
the better kept secrets maybe and i
think you know the draft community
catches on to everything but in the nfl
they don't view him as a sleeper or a
hidden gem they view him as
if he's on the board to start round
three it's not going to be very long
before his name is called
let's do a dallas dream draft they have
the 10th pick in the first round let's
say they get diablo in the third which
we're already saying sounds like a steal
who are you taking one two and what
their other third round pick as well
so the key here is dream draft right
what is the dream scenario for the
dallas cowboys i understand
their fans have talked about certain and
horn i get it
but dream draft let's think big kyle
pitts
i know they don't need more playmakers
but man it would be fun to see a super
offense with kyle pitts and if you're
the cowboys at 10
are you letting the giants or eagles
have a shot at kyle pitts
i don't think you are now you have cd
lamb amari cooper michael galp ezekiel
elliott dak prescott
and kyle pitts i somebody's got to get
the one-on-ones
it would be crazy when you look at that
that dallas draft that dallas offense
and the reason i feel okay taking kyle
pitts the bpa approach
i know dallas's needs they can solve
them in the later
rounds don't have fear round two if
fatum elephant who can come in
and be a day one starter in there any
relation to obi mel and thon wu
yes there is a relation there i believe
it's his brother so
when you look at it they are cut from
the same cloth as
amazing athletes he can run the deep
third of the field in that scheme
he's got really good reactive click and
close coming downhill
so if atum alefando was your starting
corner if you want certain or jc horn
to pick 10 i get it but i'm giving you
the solution that you can get by on
melophone who's an underrated player
people are
he could have made the sleeper show i
don't know how he doesn't go in the top
two rounds
but i wouldn't pass on him in this
situation we talked about diablo in
round three so you solved your need a
corner
you got a safety i know you have a need
on the interior of the defensive line
a lean mcneil the immovable object this
guy
knows how to contain the run clog his
gaps
uh hold the point of attack you don't
need to draft defensive tackles in round
one or two you can find guys that stop
the run in round three
round four round five elim mcneil with
the cowboy second third round pick
this is a way that they got one of the
best players in the draft
and still solve their most pressing
needs
uh connor rogers fan says that's the
most athletic draft of all time
mbr 12 to your late pick there mcneal
he has the upside and quickness off the
snap to be the best defensive tackle in
the class
and then also what do we have and then
andrew magnuson saying big slim
mcneil i'm excited to go watch him are
you ready
for app comment rapid fire q a let's go
okay uh we are gonna start with a video
comment so let's give it up to see my
folks
have to adjust for the speediest guys in
the nfl the tyree kills the jalen
waddles the daniel jones and if you have
a guy like caleb farley who reportedly
ran
24 miles an hour against notre dame
how does that speed on the defensive
side affect just how much
a defensive coordinator has to game plan
for those speedsters on offense
timeout did he just put daniel jones in
the same category as tyree kill and
jaylen waddle or does i hear the name
wrong
just a phenomenal lead-up to a question
back to the facts the numbers are the
numbers
unbelievable okay let's well done cmf
folks you are getting a
a hoodie uh connor speed of caleb farley
do offenses need to game plan
for that yeah because you know he can
run
down the field with your deep threats
one-on-one
that's the when you can island guys it
changes what you can do as a defensive
coordinator
because it takes away a matchup it cuts
down
the numbers so i think when you look at
it it is an interesting point now it's
not shocking he's
this kind of player because he was a
high school quarterback so he's more of
hey i'm the best athlete wherever i go
the ball production
was incredible 25 past deflections in 24
games lefko so you need to be careful
when targeting this guy if you go near
him
that can be points the other way he can
take the ball and bring it back to the
house you don't want to see the ball in
his hands because
quite frankly those guys on offense most
of the time not very interested in
trying to tackle in that scenario so
i think when you look at it it's a
fascinating question because
he's one of those guys that can be the
match-up player against these rare
speedsters in the nfl
but he's also someone that you might not
want to throw his way a lot because that
can
really really hurt you i have no
questions about caleb farley the athlete
or the player all the questions are
medical related
all right connor we're gonna have to go
really rapid fire cause i am about to
pee
my pants here we go b johnson227 why
aren't more people talking about kylan
hill
you know opted out early didn't explode
in mike leach's offense
i thought he'd have a little more juice
as a runner but he can make you miss i
think he can catch the ball better than
giving credit for
i think people are sleeping on him just
because you know the explosive numbers
might not have always been there and
he's not going to test as an elite
athlete he's a good one
so i think when you look at it that's
probably you know the crux of the the
main point of the argument
all right uh keep it going rapid fire
big smooth 75 lions best option at pick
number seven
man that's tricky i think they should
trade the pick honestly i think
i don't take micah parsons at seven i
know a lot of people have talked
linebacker at seven
i'm okay if you want to keep stacking
the deck at offensive line although i
don't
they don't need to i'll tell you this if
justin fields falls to seven
i don't care that you trade it for jared
goff take justin fields at seven
uh i agree and and you know what you
just admitted that you lost the bet to
me a few years ago that was perfect
uh zach eklund who is the second best
tight end in the draft
go it's probably going to be pat
fraumoth from penn state but it's not
really something that gets you too
excited
i think you look at him tommy tremble
and brevin jordan
are that next tier of guys but kyle
pitts is in a league of his own
my prostate is about to shut down connor
rogers killed it as always thank you to
everybody commenting in the app it was a
fun time
thank you with your patience earlier
today thank you to everybody watching on
twitter youtube
we are getting ready i believe next week
to announce some of the people joining
us on the desk it's going to be an
awesome time we are two weeks away 14
days
april 29th it is going to be a doozy
connor rogers i am adam lefkow we will
hala halahala at you later have a great
day everybody
[ __ ]